¿Saben qué aprendí de esto?
Aprendí que es realmente una vergüenza hablar de ello.
Aprendí a avergonzarme de mi cuerpo.
Aprendí a ignorar los períodos
con el fin de mantenerme decente.
La investigación en diversas partes de la India
muestra que 3 de cada 10 mujeres no son conscientes de la menstruación
cuando tienen sus primeros períodos.
Y en algunas partes de Rajasthan
este número es tan alto como 9 de cada 10 niñas no son conscientes de ello.
Les sorprendería saber
que la mayoría de las niñas con las que he hablado
que no sabían nada sobre el período en el momento de su primera menstruación
pensaron que tenían cáncer de la sangre
y que iban a morir pronto.
La higiene menstrual es un factor de riesgo muy importante
para infecciones del tracto reproductivo.
Pero en la India solo el 12 % de las niñas y mujeres
tienen acceso a formas de higiene para sobrellevar sus períodos.
Si se hacen las cuentas,
88 % de niñas y mujeres utilizan formas poco higiénicas durante sus períodos.
Yo era una de ellas.
Crecí en una pequeña ciudad llamada Garhwa, en Jharkhand,
donde incluso comprar una compresa higiénica se considera una vergüenza.
Así que cuando comenzaron mis períodos,
empecé a usar trapos.
Después de cada uso los lavaba y volvía a utilizarlos.
Pero para guardarlos,
me escondía y los mantenía en un lugar oscuro y húmedo
para que nadie se entera de que estaba menstruando.
Debido al lavado repetido se volvían ásperos,
y muchas veces tenía erupciones e infecciones por usarlos.
Llevaba cerca de 5 años así hasta que me fui de esa ciudad.
Otra de las cosas que los períodos trajeron a mi vida
fueron las restricciones sociales
que se imponen a nuestras niñas y mujeres cuando están en sus días.
Creo que todos deben ser conscientes de ello,
pero aun así las enumeraré para los pocos que no lo son.
No se me permitía tocar o comer pepinillos.
No se me permitía sentarme en el sofá o la cama de otro miembro de la familia.
Tenía que lavar mi sábana después de cada periodo,
incluso si no estaba manchada.
Me consideraban impura
y se me prohibía adorar o tocar cualquier objeto de importancia religiosa.
Encontraba avisos fuera de los templos
que negaban la entrada a niñas y mujeres con el periodo
Irónicamente,
la mayor parte de las veces es la mujer mayor
la que ha impuesto restricciones a las niñas más jóvenes de la familia.
Después de todo, ellas han crecido aceptando tales restricciones como normas.
Y en ausencia de cualquier intervención,
el mito y la idea errónea
se propagan de generación en generación.
Durante mis años de trabajo en este campo,
incluso he visto historias
de niñas que tienen que comer y lavar sus platos por separado.
No se les permite bañarse teniendo el período,
y en algunos hogares incluso están aisladas de otros miembros de la familia.
Alrededor del 85 % de las niñas y mujeres en la India
seguirán una o más costumbres restrictivas durante sus períodos.
¿Pueden imaginar lo que esto causa
en la autoestima y la autoconfianza de una niña?
¿El trauma psicológico que esto inflige,
que afecta a su personalidad,
su rendimiento académico
y cada aspecto del proceso de crecimiento durante sus primeros años de formación?
He seguido religiosamente todas estas costumbres restrictivas por 13 años,
hasta que una discusión con mi pareja, Tuhin,
cambió para siempre mi percepción de la menstruación.
En 2009 Tuhin y me estábamos tras nuestro posgrado en diseño.
Nos enamoramos
y yo estaba a gusto discutiendo sobre el período con él.
Tuhin sabía poco acerca de la menstruación.
(Risas)
Se sorprendió al saber que las chicas tienen calambres dolorosos
y sangrados cada mes.
(Risas)
Sí.
Estaba completamente sorprendido de saber
sobre las restricciones que se imponen a las jóvenes y mujeres que menstrúan
por sus propias familias y la sociedad.
Con el fin de ayudarme con mis calambres,
fue a Internet a aprender más acerca de la menstruación.
Cuando compartió sus hallazgos conmigo,
me di cuenta de lo poco que yo misma sabía de la menstruación.
Y muchas de mis creencias en realidad resultaron ser mitos.
Fue cuando nos preguntamos:
si nosotros, siendo tan bien educados,
estábamos tan mal informados sobre la menstruación,
habrá millones de niñas que estarán mal informadas, también.
Para estudiar...
para comprender mejor el problema,
investigué un año para estudiar la falta de conciencia sobre la menstruación
y la causa fundamental detrás.
Aunque generalmente se cree
que el desconocimiento menstrual es un fenómeno rural,
durante mi investigación,
encontré que es también un fenómeno urbano.
Y es que existe en la clase urbana educada, también.
Mientras hablaba con muchos padres y profesores,
descubrí que muchos realmente querían informar a las niñas sobre el período
antes de que comenzaran a tener su ciclo menstrual.
Y...
pero carecían de medios adecuados ellos mismos.
Y puesto que es un tabú,
se inhiben y les da vergüenza hablar de ello.
Las niñas hoy tienen la menstruación en las clases de sexto y séptimo,
pero nuestro plan de estudios
enseña a las niñas sobre el período solo en octavo o noveno.
Y puesto que es un tabú,
los maestros todavía se saltan el tema por completo.
Así que la escuela no enseña a las niñas sobre el período,
los padres no hablan de ello.
¿A dónde van las chicas?
Hace dos décadas y ahora...
nada ha cambiado.
Compartí estos hallazgos con Tuhin y nos preguntamos:
¿Y si pudiéramos crear algo
que ayudara a entender las niñas la menstruación por cuenta propia,
algo que ayudara a padres y profesores
a hablar del período cómodamente a las jóvenes?
Durante mi investigación,
recolecté un montón de historias.
Fueron historias de experiencias de las niñas durante su período.
Estas historias despertarían a las niñas la curiosidad y el interés
de hablar de la menstruación en su círculo cercano.
Eso es lo que queríamos.
Queríamos algo que despertara a las niñas la curiosidad
y las llevara a aprender del tema.
Queríamos usar estas historias para enseñarles sobre el período.
Así que decidimos crear un cómic,
donde los personajes de dibujos animados promulgaran estas historias
y educaran sobre la menstruación a las niñas de manera divertida y atractiva.
Para representar a las niñas en sus diferentes fases de la pubertad,
tenemos 3 caracteres.
Pinki, que no ha tenido su período aún.
Jiya que tiene el período durante el curso del relato del libro
y Mira que ya tiene su período.
Hay un cuarto personaje, Priya Didi.
A través de ella, las niñas saben de los diversos aspectos del crecimiento
y de como llevar la higiene menstrual.
Al hacer el libro, tuvimos gran cuidado
de que ninguna de las ilustraciones fueran objetables en modo alguno
y que fuera sensible culturalmente.
Durante la prueba del prototipo, vimos que a las chicas les encantó el libro.